this week politics wanders blindly onto
a grim unknown planet where half the
world is guilty
guess who's perpetuating all of these
kinds of actions it's a man in this
country and I just want to say to the
men in this country just shut up and
step up do the right thing for a change
mm-hmm you know maybe the right thing is
to not generalize unless of course you
include your husband in the men in this
country speaking of husbands your
husband certainly our concerns of the
time that he never really had due
process to defend himself from
allegations like this have we learned
anything over the years about due
process not just for the accusers but
also for the accused well I think that
you have to take each of these
situations sort of on their own merits
yes there should be due process for
everyone involved and I think that's
what dr. Ford is asking for she's asking
for due process she's asking that there
be an investigation that was genius she
spun due process for her accused bill
into due process for dr. Ford I have to
and a door but today the burdens on the
accused to prove ones innocence even
with an event decades ago that's unclear
even to the accuser so now the Dems have
gone from barking one man to barking a
system an accusation is all you need the
legal system becomes a game of tag plus
if saying that the accused is presumed
innocent is now seen as pro abuse why
not rid us of courts altogether just
rely on memory the media thinks it's
foolproof but is it
Hillary believes she ran from sniper
fire and didn't believe Juanita
Blumenthal believed he was in Nam Brian
Williams believed to everything he said
on talk shows but memory is fallible for
all and that's for accuser and the
accused it's just shocking how fast the
media fires when they see the desired
moving target and after sitting on it
for many months
Feinstein gave that target to them but
says the mob let's not rush things we've
got all day as they twirl their rope but
what of the media
at work they swarm but at home do they
look at their spouse or kid and think
what if this ever happens to them people
loved Shakespeare's tragedies because
afterward you could go home and say hey
I'm glad I'm not Julius Caesar it made
you welcome a humble life no more today
we're all Caesars facing a mob of
Brutus's armed with press passes shaped
like daggers and microphones alright
Jesse we need to hear from her don't we
we do I don't think we are going to I
think what happened was is they thought
they were going to take it up to a
certain point and then they realized
that this woman was going to have to
testify Monday and that was way too soon
for the Democrats because this was a
delay tactic and this is a really dirty
business and for that reason today I am
withdrawing from consideration from the
Supreme Court because it's ugly and
they're destroying this guy's life and I
wanted to give for the benefit of the
doubt in the beginning you remember on
Monday and Tuesday I've been saying I
believe she believes something happens
something may have happened there was a
polygraph involved I don't want to cast
any doubt on her allegations but the way
they're dragging this out now it's
become so political Greg that it's it's
gotten away from the actual alleged
crime and now it's about the process and
the nomination of this guy
she's not doing things and the Democrats
aren't doing things in a way that people
would do if she was a true victim if you
go out and you say the first thing you
hear Cavanaugh's name you call the
Washington Post and then you call your
congresswoman and then you call Dianne
Feinstein and you say you don't want to
come forward because you want to be
anonymous but at the same time you take
a polygraph test and when they ask you
how'd you pay for the polygraph you
don't say how you paid for it and then
you hire a Clinton fundraiser as your
lawyer to represent you and now it looks
like there's some behind-the-scenes
stuff where Brian Fallon who worked for
Hillary Clinton has teamed up with Paige
herwig who worked for Dianne Feinstein
and they've raised five million dollars
a lot from George Soros to fund a group
called demand justice and demand justice
is the main work
that's running to stop the Cavanaugh
nomination and they're working in
concert with Deborah Katz the lawyer for
Ford it's just way way too suspicious
what's going on I wanted to believe her
I still kind of believe she believes
something happened but it doesn't sit
right anything the time he makes it
suspicious but at one I think we learned
here the real tragedy is that we're
going to lose people like Jesse from the
Supreme Court imagine that here in that
road think of all the water's worlds
they'd have to go through oh man I would
demand the Jesse's mother testify
[Laughter]
watch one if she doesn't testify after
going through this entire process that's
what the Republicans do but just vote
right they can do it but they would do
it at great risk because I think they
would be seen as bullies the question is
about the process here and it's about
the demand that she's making that there
be an investigation before she testifies
so that they are testifying about known
facts they can drive some points of
commonality in the narrative and it's
not just he said she said
but clearly the FBI says there was no
federal crime committed because this is
a matter of I would guess if it was an
assault Maryland law back at that period
it's a distinction we made from when
Anita Hill said that Clarence Thomas was
harassing her while she was working for
him in the federal government right the
problem here is that I think that there
is an effort by the Republicans to say
we don't want any more investigation we
don't want anything we just want to get
a vote done and it seems like they're
rushing along as you say there's a risk
for them but isn't Senator Grassley
trying to get this dude there aren't
they kind of bending over backwards to
meet with this women and privately or
publicly even aren't they willing to fly
to see her they're doing everything
possible
I personally think that the Republicans
are doing the due process that they're
saying that they're denying her it's not
their fault that this came so late in
the game so far into the process there
very accommodating at this point and it
does seem that dr. Ford doesn't
necessarily want to talk at this point
she's probably not gonna be there Monday
I'm not sure she's gonna allow anyone to
go there and as it stands we just have
all these hazy details so if we're not
gonna get details to help prove or
disprove her claims they have to vote
yes thank you guys why are you guys
saying that she won't be there
well let's connect I read her lawyer no
Lord did not say that her lawyer said
that she would like an investigation but
it didn't she didn't preclude the idea
but there is not going to be an FBI
investing to the fact that she is saying
I would like an investigation if you say
I want an investigation then she knows
that it's not gonna happen
oh no so why would you say that I think
you don't know I think I'm is like a
novel we don't know where it's going
that's a good point Dana um do you want
to what's gonna rule then Grassley stuff
but I think we've we're past Grassley
okay we're past him the grass is grown
the grass is growing faster no he was
talking about the possibility should we
roll it and should I stop talking about
it okay let's play it let's play it I
can't believe I wasted time I'm focused
right now is doing everything that we
can to make dr. Ford comfortable with
coming before our committee either in an
open session or a closed session or a
public or a private interview I have
hopes that this person who pleaded
through the Washington Post and I didn't
learn about anything about this until I
read her name in the Washington Post
Dana well people are complaining about
process on the Republican side I think
the Republicans have a lot to complain
about with the Democrats on the process
side Dianne Feinstein getting this
letter through a congressman issues
office in July
having it there in fact Dianne Feinstein
has since said I kind of regret I wish I
could have maybe I should have because
she knows she's a statesman she knows it
was wrong to not loop them in earlier
they Kate's person she's in now in a
very tough election you have demand
justice which is a new group and they
realize the Democrats that they spent
three decades basically not caring about
judicial nominations and the Republicans
conservatives have been very good about
it I think the Republicans have been
quite risk
well the language has been responsible
okay she should be heard she should not
be insulted that was the first thing
Kellyanne Conway said and everyone
followed that lead and the president has
been quite muted about it and everyone's
waited like you are you can be heard you
will be heard there is a question about
this idea Judge Napolitano said earlier
on the 2 o'clock show should the
president asked the FBI to take two
weeks see what you can find out and at
the end of that then vote on him and
allow him to get seated by November
first rather than October first that's
not what the Democrats want I don't
think they're ever ever going to be
satisfied even if there is an FBI
investigation that says there's nothing
there that won't ever matter like
because basically the die is cast and
that's why I feel that they might just
need to cast the vote all right we're
gonna talk about this in the upcoming
block so we'll just sit here quietly to
be continued yes and read our tweets